i think that
the underlying premise behind twitter
all these networks is amazing that we
can communicate with each other and
and i use it a lot there's a subpart of
twitter called econ twitter where you
know we economists uh
tweet to each other and talk about new
papers something came out in the nber
the national bureau of economic research
and we share about it
people critique it i think it's been a
godsend because
it's really sped up the scientific
process if you can call economic
scientific
does it get divisive and that little
sometimes yeah sure sometimes it does it
can also be done in
nasty ways and you know there's the bad
parts but the good parts are great
because you just speed up that clock
speed of learning about things
you know instead of like in the old old
days you know waiting to read in a
journal
or the not so old days when you'd see it
posted on
on a website and you'd read it now on
twitter like people will distill it down
and there's a real art
to getting to the essence of things so
that's been great
um but um it certainly we all know that
twitter can be a cesspool
of misinformation and like i just said
unfortunately misinformation tends to
spread faster on twitter
than truth and there are a lot of people
who are very vulnerable to it i'm sure
i've been fooled at times there are
agents whether from russia or from
political groups or
others that explicitly create efforts
that misinformation and
efforts at getting people to hate each
other or even more important lately i've
discovered is uh
is nut picking you know the idea of nut
picking what's that it's a good term
um nut picking is when you find like an
extreme
nut case on the other side and then you
amplify them
and make it seem like that's typical of
the other side so you're not literally
lying
you're taking some idiot you know
renting on the subway
or just you know whether they're in the
kkk or antifa or whatever they just
and you normally nobody would pay
attention this guy like 12 people would
see i'm going to be the end
instead with video or whatever
you you get tens of millions of people
say it
and i've seen this you know i look at it
like i get angry i'm like i can't
believe that person did something
exactly so terrible
let me tell my friends about this person
and uh and it's uh it's a great way to
generate division i
i i talked to a friend who studied
russian misinformation campaigns
and they're very clever about literally
being on both sides of some of these
debates
they would have some people pretend to
be part of blm some
people pretend to be white nationalists
and they would be throwing epithets at
each other saying crazy things at each
other
and they're literally playing both sides
of it but their goal wasn't for one or
the other to win
it was for everybody to get behating and
distrusting everyone else
so these tools can definitely be used
for that and they are being used for
that
it's been super destructive for our
democracy and our society
and the people who run these platforms i
think have
a social responsibility a moral and
ethical personal responsibility
to do a better job and to shut that
stuff down as
well i don't shut it down but to design
them in a way that
that you know as i said earlier favors
truth over over falsehoods and favors
positive types of um
uh communication versus destructive ones
and just like you said it's also on us
i try to be all about love and
compassion empathy on twitter i mean one
of the things
not picking is a fascinating term one of
the things that people do
that's i think even more dangerous is
not picking applied to individual
statements
of good people so basically worst case
analysis
in computer science is uh taking
sometimes out of context but sometimes
in context
a statement one statement right by a
person
uh like i've been because i've been
reading the rise and fall of the third
reich
i'd often talk about uh hitler on this
podcast with folks
and it is so easy really dangerous
but i'm all leaning in i'm 100 because
well
it's actually a safer place than people
realize because
it's history in history in long form is
actually very fascinating uh
to think about and it's but i could see
how that could be taken
yeah totally out of context and it's
very worrying about the you know these
digital infrastructures not just these
disseminations but they're sort of
permanent so anything you say at some
point someone can go back and find
something you said three years ago
perhaps jokingly perhaps not maybe
you're just wrong and you made them you
know
and like that becomes they can use that
to define you if they have uh
intent and we all need to be a little
more forgiving i mean
somewhere in my twenties i i i told my i
was going through all my different
friends and i was like
you know every one of them has at least
like one
nutty opinion yeah exactly i was like
there's like nobody who's like
completely
except me of course yeah but i'm sure
they thought that about me too and
uh and she just kind of like learned to
be a little bit tolerant that like okay
there's just you know
uh yeah i i wonder who the
responsibility
lays on there like i think ultimately
it's about
leadership like uh the previous
president
barack obama has been i think quite
eloquent at walking this very difficult
line of talking about cancer culture
but it's difficult it takes skill yeah
because you say the wrong thing and you
piss off a lot of people
and so you have to do it well but then
also the platform the technology is
should slow down create friction and
spreading this kind of nut picking in
all its forms
absolutely no and and your point that we
have to like learn over time how to
manage it i mean we can't put it all on
the platform and say you guys design it
and because if we're idiots about using
it you know
nobody can present a platform that
withstands that and
and every new technology people learn
it's dangerous you know when someone
invented fire
it's great cooking and everything but
then somebody burned himself and then
you had to like learn
how to like avoid maybe somebody
invented a fire extinguisher later and
what stuff
so you kind of like figure out ways of
of working around these technologies
someone invented seat belts etc
um and and that's certainly true with
all the new digital technologies that
we have to figure out not just
technologies that protect us but but
ways of using them
that um emphasize that are more likely
to be successful than dangerous
you